La volta al món a peu, dia 275, surto de la Guesthouse Homestay que he estat aquesta nit,
esmorzar de 10, esmorzar de 10 i comencem a caminar, són les 8 i 10, 8 i quart,
bastant més tard de l'habitual però clar, s'estava tan bé, he pogut esmorzar, ja he assegut,
he pogut anar al lavabo, ja avui estic cobert d'aquest tema, molt bé tu,
he dormit bé, el llit era còmode, un 10 per aquest lloc, 20 euros.
Molt bé, avui el termòmetre marca que les temperatures màximes baixaran dràsticament 5 graus,
no m'encavo, no acabo de refiar-me d'això, tant de bo, creu els dits.
Mira, jo l'únic que espero és que el paisatge sigui tan magó com ahir,
perquè amb l'aipols ja hi compto, amb el cansament ja hi compto
i a tot això, gràcies.
De cada dia, ja ho tenim, però el paisatge que sigui així, tan magó com ahir.
Som-hi!
De cada dia, ja ho tenim.
Des d'ahir a la tarda, avui, el canvi és molt gran.
Ja us vaig parlar ahir de la vestimenta i la manera de tal.
Les cases es veuen més diferents, mireu aquest tipus de tanques que estan molt ben fetes.
Veig més diners, més desenvolupament.
Sí, la gent saluda igual, la gent és simpàtica igual,
però es veu que és... el color de la pell també de la gent trobo que és més blanc.
Una altra, no sé, una altra ètnia o el que sigui.
Ara he anat a un supermercat i li he preguntat com es deia gràcies i m'ha dit que kloch,
no kaloch que us vaig dir, kloch.
Ara crec que ja ho tenim, com es diu, gràcies.
I què més? Tema de xalles.
Això és comú, tant aquí com tot l'Azèquistan, és un país que no està brut.
Ja, de tant en quant, doncs hi ha unes per aquí, ampolles sí que les hi ha, però no més que qualsevol altre país que hagi anat.
I el més fort és que no hi ha escombraries.
No he trobat ni un sol contenidor en tot el país.
Jo això ho trobo fatal, però... però no, no, no, i això no està brut.
Llavors, com ho fa la gent? Doncs no ho sé.
Jo crec que cremen les de xalles.
No ho sé, eh? No puc demostrar-ho, però diria que és el que fan perquè tampoc he vist que canvio d'escombraries, que se'n porti d'escombraries, no ho sé.
I jo com ho faig per tirar les meves de xalles?
Doncs a cada supermercat a fora tenen un cubell petit i allà tiro el que tinc.
Però molts cops ho he de portar migdia o un dia sense les meves de xalles perquè no trobo el supermercat o el que sigui.
Mireu, eh? És que la manera de vestir i tal és diferent.
Avui, per cert, és 31 d'agost, dilluns.
Molts de vosaltres avui és quan acabeu les vacances i comenceu la rutina un altre cop, ja comptant els dies fins al Nadal.
Altres, encara amb mi, fins a mitjans de setembre, doncs encara teniu una mica de vacances.
Jo res, jo continuo igual.
I la temperatura, què?
Bueno, encara no són ni les 11.
De moment, bé, sí. No sabria dir si hi ha un canvi, jo diria que sí.
L'única mica menys de calor fa, no ho sé.
Però bueno, m'està agradant molt aquest matí, com veieu.
Ja no estic caminant al costat del riu, allò que tinc a Afghanistan super a prop.
Està aquí, estic veient a Afghanistan, aquestes muntanyes d'aquí dalt.
Però està una mica més lluny, aquesta zona verda, maca.
Let's go!
L'Arabia
Les 12 i 10, he arribat a Roshan.
Una ciutat bastant gran, la més gran des de que vaig anar a la primera frontera d'Afghanistan, que em vaig quedar en un hotel.
Doncs sí, doncs sí.
Hi ha taxis.
M'han dit, ei, vas a Dushanbe, no sé què.
Bueno, doncs no tinc gaire gana, perquè és un rat fort, però anem a buscar alguna cosa de dinar.
Aquí tinc diverses opcions, hi ha bastants restaurants.
A veure si trobo alguna cosa una mica diferent, que no sigui el mateix de sempre.
Mira on estic.
Ara un petit tram de camí.
Camí on la gent passeja al costat del riu.
Aquí hi ha uns aiguamolls.
Es veu?
Jo he vist abans un ànec.
I més enllà està el riu principal.
I ara, bueno, és un tram petit, eh.
D'aquí a poc ja tornem a enganxar amb la carretera.
He dinat a la sempre, al final.
Carn amb amanida.
Tampoc.
Carn de xai, està bé, ok.
Però bueno.
No, no, poques novetats.
Aquesta és la població en la que m'hauria de decidir si al final em desvio per la ruta que us vaig dir ahir o la ruta original.
És dura igualment, però crec que té menys incerteses, crec que tinc més clar el dia que podria arribar a la Xina.
I ja està.
Ja m'havia fet la idea d'això, i ja està.
També té un tram que farem de natura, de sense cotxe, sense camions.
Doncs ja està.
Em quedo que farem aquest tram.
Val.
Una trenta.
Ara seria l'hora de calor i sol màxim.
I sí, sí, sí, fa una mica menys.
Fa calor, però bé.
S'està millor que ahir.
Sí.
Les tres de la tarda gairebé.
Està sent un dia fantàstic, el millor dia.
El millor dia des que estic per aquí, per l'Afganistan, Tajikistan.
La veritat, jo crec que és per la temperatura.
Quan n'hi penso dic, ostres, tu, és que m'encanta el paisatge, no sé què, no.
Jo crec que és que ara és tranquil perquè no m'estic torrant.
Però el paisatge, a part d'això, mola, eh?
Mola molt, mola molt.
A més, no hi ha gaire cotxes.
No entenc el per què, no hi ha gaires camions.
Però millor tu, millor.
Molt bé tu.
Molt tranquil, molt tranquil.
Vaig escoltant podcast avui, música, vaig pensant les meves coses.
Jo també.
Les quatre i pico, a punt d'arribar a l'ombra.
aquests prats, eh?
Bueno, prats una mica guamois, eh?
Perquè veieu aquí que hi ha un...
una mica de llacs, però bueno.
Ara que trobés un lloc sec aquí
per acampar ara ja...
Joc maquíssim, eh?
Dels més macos de Tajikistan
avui, eh? Exceptuant
el lloc insuperable de la
glacera.
Molt maco, però avui vull fer 40.
Vull fer 40 o 41, 42.
Perquè així demà només em queden 40
per arribar al poble aquell.
I demà passat descansar.
Demà passat no caminar. És el meu objectiu.
Primers camions de la tarda.
A veure si avui també hi ha trànsit.
Mira què porten. Una excavadora, tu.
Marca
Caterpillar.
Retroexcavadora
amb implement cullera.
Això és per moviment de terres.
Mira, allà n'hi ha una altra.
Caterpillar crec que és marca americana, no?
Doncs ara no ho sé.
Sí, sí, sí.
Caterpillar també.
Bueno, és que aquest país...
Jo una altra cosa no he vist,
però moviment de terres a sac.
Jo estava esperant veure un enderrock
per poder-vos parlar de Demeter.
Demeter, empresa pionera
i puntera d'enderrocks a Catalunya.
També fan moviments de terres.
Però crec que aquí,
o sigui, a Tajikistan el que estic veient és
moviments de terres sobretot dedicats
a la terra.
A fer carreteres.
Que no seria l'especialitat de Demeter.
Demeter enderrocks moviments de terres
descontaminacions.
És a dir, quan hi ha hagut una fàbrica
a un lloc, s'han enderrocat la fàbrica
i han descobert que
hi havia filtracions de gasolina o de productes químics
a la terra, clar, això s'ha de netejar
abans de posar allà un parc per nens, no?
Doncs això ho fa Demeter. No és fàcil de fer això.
Demeter Caterpillars no en té.
Aquesta marca no la toquen.
Tenen Volvo,
que és sueca,
Eber, crec que és alemanya,
i totes pròpies,
maquinària pròpia, no han de s'ho contratar.
També el personal propi, els maquinistes de la màquina,
no han de s'ho contratar.
Més control sobre el procés i més qualitat.
Confio en Demeter
pels vostres enderrocks,
descontaminacions i moviments de terres.
Gràcies, Demeter.
Hi ha uns tios a l'altra banda de la frontera
cridant
ara ja hem parat
i ha sobresentit una explosió.
Dues explosions.
I m'he girat i he vist un núvol de sorra
allà dalt de la muntanya.
No tinc ni idea de què ha passat aquí.
No tinc ni idea.
Els crits aquests, no és el primer cop que ho sento
mentre estic caminant al costat afganès.
Tampoc hi donava més importància.
Sí, pot ser qualsevol cosa que els agradi cridar això o el que sigui.
Però clar, és que ha coincidit amb...
No ho sé.
No haurà sigut una bomba, no?
Espero que no.
Una altra.
Una altra, tercera.
Tercera explosió, eh?
A veure, pot ser
una explosió controlada per
per tirar unes pedres i fer un camí.
Ho dubto molt.
Ai, ai, ai.
Me l'aspiro ràpid.
Aquest poble d'aquí,
tan bucòlic que tinc al davant,
amb aquests prats i aquests arbres,
és on tinc intenció de dormir avui, a campar.
Encara és molt d'hora, són les sis.
Però pel que he vist,
els següents cinc quilòmetres,
que seria el que podria cobrir
abans que se'm fes fosc,
no hi ha cap lloc que m'acabi de traure.
En aquest poble tampoc.
És a dir, no sé si hi ha una àrea
on jo pugui estar sense ser vist,
fora de les cases i tal.
Crec que no, però bueno.
Si em veu algú, doncs ja està.
Ja estic acostumat, saps?
Bueno, a veure què hi ha.
Home, vist des d'aquí,
posar la tenda allà,
a la vora del riu,
seria molt guai.
Però no sé si puc,
perquè potser són camps
que fa servir la gent per plantar coses, saps?
Estic enmig de la vila
i uns nens
m'han dit que
que vagi a jugar a futbol.
Estic rebentat
per jugar a futbol ara.
Però aquest lloc m'encanta
per acampar, llavors.
Vaig a intentar-me fer un amic seu.
Bue, ara posar-me a fer sprints.
Gol!
Gol, gol, gol!
Hello!
How are you?
Who's winning?
You're winning. Real Madrid?
I'm from Barcelona.
I'm Barça.
Barcelona.
Visca Barça.
Yes.
Okay, I can play
two minutes. I'm tired.
No sé amb qui vaig, eh?
Ui, ui!
Gol!
Posa la samarreta de Vinicius a sobre del tio.
Good!
Good, good. Very, very fast.
You are very fast.
Ah, som tres contra...
Som dos contra quatre? Ah, no.
Tres contra tres, va.
Que malo que sóc.
No, fora, fora, fora.
Ui, ni de conya, ni de conya.
Vaig a fer un sprint.
Vinga, córner.
De cap els guanyo.
Ah, no.
Oh! Neva!
Oh!
Ah, no!
Casi.
He parat el track, eh? Això no compta.
No.
Vale.
Oh!
Pellissa.
L'última, va.
Last one.
No.
Nothing, nothing.
Vale.
No.
Okay, good game.
Good game.
I...
I want to camp.
Yes. Camp.
Here. It's okay?
No problem. Yes.
Rachmat.
Kloch.
Ara els deixo tirats, eh?
Deixo tirats. Els del meu equip.
Jo els he preguntat si hi ha un problema per acampar aquí.
M'han dit que no.
Tampoc crec que ells siguin
qui han de donar autorització,
però, vamos, això no està
plantat.
Ni hi ha vaques,
a part d'aquella que està lligada.
Ni reto.
És qüestió d'escollir el lloc.
Allà està bé.
Aquí està bé, també.
Bueno.
Muque.
D'acord, doncs els militars
m'han dit, cosa que jo no
sabia, que a partir
de les cinc de la tarda no pots estar a prop de la frontera
amb l'Afganistan. I jo
deixàvem el traductor en rus,
que hem estat una bona estona.
Simpàtics, eh?
Després em diuen, però demanaré permís
per a veure si et pots quedar.
Mentre estaven demanant permís
a algú, no ho sé, aquests nois
tan simpàtics amb els que he jugat
a futbol abans i parlen un pèl d'anglès,
m'han dit que em conviden al jardí
a casa seva. Llavors els he dit als militars,
mira, escolta, que m'han convidat al jardí,
llavors no cal que demanis permís a ningú, i ja està.
I
the mother of this gentleman here
és una professora d'anglès.
Llavors, home, doncs
em podré comunicar, està bé. I aquí estic.
Portant la tenda
autoportant per tot el poble,
per no haver-la de desmuntar.
Surrealista.
Però tu, genial.
Genial.
Bueno, moltes coses. Espero que em sentiu bé
perquè hi ha bastant de soroll de l'aigua.
Bueno, m'han convidat
a sopar,
a part de dormir. I no dormiria
al jardí, dormiria a la típica
plataforma que us he dit
diverses vegades
aquí al jardí de la casa aquesta.
I sí, sí,
el sopar ha sigut, doncs, pollastre,
que em venia molt de gust. Feia dies que no menjava
pollastre. Pedrades fregides, que estaven
molt ben cuites. I
amanida, per variar. I pa.
Molt bé, molt bé, molt bé.
M'ha explicat,
bueno, la mare, que és professora d'anglès,
diu, ostres, jo és que no tinc molt bon nivell
d'anglès. M'agradaria
millorar-lo, però
clar, no tinc ningú amb qui
practicar-lo. I es veu que
soc la primera persona, el primer turista que
que acullen
a casa i tal. Molt bé, molt
simpàtics, molt simpàtics. Bueno, què més m'ha dit?
M'ha dit que aquí, en aquesta
zona del país, les dones no porten
el jihad. I m'ha dit
que són lliures.
O més lliures, no.
Ha quedat molt clar com ho ha expressat,
no? Però ho ha dit així, sí.
Ho ha dit així.
I què més? Molt interessant, m'ha
ensenyat casa seva.
M'han dit, casa típica del Pamir.
Vols veure-la? I jo sí, sí, oi tant.
I dic, ostres, això està molt
buit, tal. On estan
els llits? Es veu que no dormen
en llits. No, no dormen en llits,
dormen al terra, a catifes.
Estan
acostumats i estan acostumats, però a mi em sembla
molt sorprenent.
I després, aquesta espècie de
sala amb
aquesta espècie de grades,
tan...
Bueno, sorprenent.
Allà és on fan vida, especialment
a l'hivern. A l'hivern,
fa molt de fred a fora, llavors
mengen, estan allà tot el dia
i dormen a la mateixa sala.
On no fa fred perquè sempre
tenen la llenya i l'estufa
que està calentant, escalfant.
Trobo que, molt
interessant. La casa és nova, igualment
suposo que per això està tan buida, perquè
es veu que fa un any que la van construir.
I bueno, quan és estiu, doncs
estan més aquí fora,
en aquesta zona d'aquí.
Molt,
molt, molt, molt interessant.
Molt interessant.
Què més? Les bombes.
Les explosions.
He preguntat, escolta, això
d'Afganistan, que avui he sentit aquest soroll,
és un atemptat? És una bomba?
I diu, no, no, no, no,
això és que els afganesos
estan buscant or.
I quan comença la primavera, comencen a fer això
per buscar or. I home, vale, va.
Em deixes molt més tranquil, si em dius això.
Em dius molt
més tranquil. Demà,
1 de setembre, és el primer dia d'escola
aquí a Tajikistan.
I ara,
fa una estona s'han anat a preparar
les motxilles pel dia de demà,
que no pensis que han d'anar molt lluny, perquè l'escola
la tenen a 20 metres.
O sigui, just darrere d'aquí, a 20 metres
està l'escola, i la mare és professora
d'anglès. Avui,
en aquesta escola, el nivell era bastant
alt. No només el
noi que m'ha convidat a casa seva, sinó els dos amics.
He pogut parlar
bastant bé amb ells
en anglès. I això que tenien
12 anys. He fet aquesta foto,
que no es veu gaire bé perquè és de nit
i tal, a veure si demà en puc fer una altra
de la família, que m'han
seguit a l'Instagram, m'han agregat
el WhatsApp, tot, tot.
Espectacular
l'hospitalitat i l'amabilitat i
tot plegat. Molt bé.
Molt content, molt content.
Avui 40 km,
demà haurem de fer 43,
es pot fer, encara que suposo
que sortiré tard perquè
hauré d'esmorzar amb ells,
amb molt de gust, però esmorzaré
amb ells i tal. I
que més tres refrescos...
Avui te he begut? No, avui no he begut
te. Cap te.
I he parlat amb
posa-li
7-8 persones. Avui
ha sigut un gran dia, un gran dia.
L'únic moment, el de
l'explosió, i el moment
que m'han dit, te n'has de
anar d'aquí.
Després hem pogut solucionar i al final
el resultat ha sigut molt bo. Però
però sí, no, no.
Dels millors dies de
d'últimament.
No sé si m'oblido alguna cosa perquè havia
d'explicar bastantes coses, però diria que ja està.
Sí.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Doncs això, demà
últims 43 km fins al
meu repòs. Bona nit.
Bona nit.